Sam once again just like last year you
were with the back against the wall and
we saw you on the camera you weren't
very happy after you lost that first
game in the 10 plus five what did you
say to yourself
you don't want me to repeat that I said
to myself I mean I was very upset of
course I believe I was totally fine and
just had to sit and do nothing and
failed to do so that's usually how
people beat me in Rapid it never works
in classical like people tried it never
works against me but like in rapper
that's how I lost to Wesley as well
which was a really painful matches but
uh well I'd been studying the Berlin on
game a lot I said you know I got huge
winning chances the first game let's
give it another try and I was able to
finally break through and you came back
with an incredible strategy you played
that move Bishop to B2 in the first game
he knew how to react to that and then
you came with this Knight D5 idea yeah
that you have this prepared yeah of
course I mean I did a lot of work on the
Berlin on game recently and so as you
saw I mean I played a lot of them over
and over here and I kept getting really
good positions with lights so it has
paid off but yeah I mean I I knew that
Bishop B2 and Knight D5 were both
challenging those I thought Bishop B2 is
the better one so I played it against
him the first game I didn't repeat it
again because I believe ultimately
Black's basically fine
um but yeah I came with Knight D5 which
is a little trickier and in the last
game he shied away from the Berlin play
day six and he took on C6 I haven't seen
that since my childhood yeah I mean
basically when I studied the Berlin
endgame I said if because we all know
that Black's fine objectively in the
Berlin Berlin and game I said why not
just play the same end games again in
equal positions there's no doubt black
is absolutely fine exchange Spanish does
not bust the Royal love that's great you
know I just I checked this end game a
bit up soon I think after he misplayed
it a little I mean already after E6 I
know that I know that I know here after
E6 the computer claims it's about equal
but
come on it's the Berlin pawn star
shouldn't I haven't pushed the pawn to
E5 yet I thought at least I can play and
next thing I knew I had a very nice
position and
when did you feel like you finally are
taking it well already here I knew that
white was better I didn't
know how much and then I think he didn't
coordinate his pieces right if I'm not
mistaken he's supposed to uh go with
Knight h8 and then bring the Knight to
D6 at some points like I know that's not
the computer defines it's not pleasant
and here it's already a bad version but
like he's definitely supposed to bring
the Knight to D6 and when he didn't do
that like already this just looks really
bad and
here I mean he could have taken my
e-pawn if I'm not mistaken at some point
like instead of A4 yeah I mean here he
should take you for it like I mean it's
obviously miserable with the horrible
structure but at least he's not just
straight Pawn down which he got in the
game like here I just I saved E4 pawn
and got the same position I mean here
like well it's obviously much better but
in Blitz like this is far from routine
Samuel you played so many games against
Ray uh last year this year what made the
difference this year well
um
I think uh
I guess I got a little bit fortunate
like I definitely I haven't checked the
mission but I feel I should have lost
the second game I also should have won
the first one but uh yeah I don't know I
mean um it's funny last year at the time
I would have said I was clearly the
better classical player and he was
clearly the better rapid player and it
sort of showed this year I think you
know our ratings are sort of the same in
both ways so he's improved a lot in
classical like it really shows like he's
so much stronger now than he has been
but you know look I've known Ray since
we were since you know
since we were like whatever 12 and 9 or
something like you know we're the two uh
best players to have come out of America
from our generation and um
and uh yes I've just known him forever I
mean we've had so many games I know I'm
pretty well guys any questions our
congratulations and uh good luck as you
move on in the tournament uh Sam oh I
have a question who do I play next
you're gonna have to watch the show
we actually we're not sure we're not
sure but I'm not playing tomorrow I
believe it will be the loser between
Nakamura and Dominguez tomorrow you have
a wrestling okay that's for sure okay
I like that I have a question for